le président français accompagné du
chancelier allemand et du chef du
gouvernement italien sont arrivés à kiev
ce matin les trois dirigeants ont fait
route vers la capitale ukrainienne à
bord d'un train spécial depuis la
pologne l'imaginer ce matin dans un
train vers l'ukraine comme s'ils
pouvaient pas dans de la semaine
prochaine alors que l'extrême gauche
eto'o est quand même aujourd'hui hyper
menaçante et et à vocation des stades
il est dans le train pour réaliser ce
pas qu'il a raison c'est surtout que
c'est d'une légèreté incroyable 8 à 10
heures de train pour rejoindre kiev et
enfin retrouvé volodymyr et l'ins qui
ils vont se reposer dans ce genre de
couchettes des couches est assez
sommaire l'image est historique côte à
côte le président français le chancelier
allemand et le premier ministre italien
découvre la ville d'hier pin détruite à
près de 80% que cette visite aurait été
plus efficace et mieux comprise celle
avait été organisée plus tôt je vous le
dis au lendemain de la réélection de
monsieur macron il avait du temps vous
pouvez organiser son gouvernement plus
vite après on peut évidemment
s'interroger sur le sens de ce voyage
mais comme il est à l'étranger sur une
zone de guerre je propose qu'on évite
drôle et polémiques l'armée russe a été
arrêté à côté de plusieurs autres villes
des massacres ont écarté flou
les premières traces parce que ce sont
des crimes de guerre je suis toujours
prudent sur ses mises en scène la
diplomatie ça se fait pas devant les
écrans de télé à grand renfort ce qu'un
grand renfort de publicité et de
communication image entre dans
l'histoire ils sont en train de discuter
d'échanger emmanuel mac on ne fait
jamais rien on ne dit jamais rien sans
avoir une arrière pensée électoraliste
voilà c'est malheureux c'est peut-être
les signes du temps mais qui aime ce
matin et une arrière pensée et les
beaucoup mais en tout cas c'est une
suspicion qui peut exister personne
n'est dupe sur le fait que c'est à trois
jours que ce déplacement dont on parlait
beaucoup à trois jours du second tour
qui va déterminant pour la vie politique
française que monsieur mac ont fait des
images avec monsieur chose le statut de
candidat à l'adhésion pour l'ukraine est
une chance historique de renforcer la
stabilité européenne et elle être une
des plus grandes décisions de cette
première moitié du xxième siècle malgré
les agressions du pc il faudra trouver
un chemin pour le peuple russe où on
n'est pas dans une forme d'enfermement
dans l'histoire il ya aucune ambiguïté
sur le fait que vladimir poutine hélas
câble j'allais les soeurs souple
l'ukraine et que nous souhaitons la
victoire de l'ukraine quand il a osé
dire que voter pour lui c'était pas une
voix ne doit manquer pour la république
sous-entendu quiconque ne vote pas pour
les candidats de monsieur macron et en
dehors de la république ça ça ne choque
j'avais juste du mal à utiliser le
slogan de l'anus mélenchon premier
ministre déjà ça me fait chier qu on
personnalise à ce pont l'élection
présidentielle et le faire une élection
jce la tipp pour le parlement c'est
pareil et là en face on a de l'estimé de
la fébrilité de l'arrogance des insultes
qu'on puisse travailler ensemble avec
jean luc mélenchon avec olivier faure
avec olivier mailloux avec olivier
julien dray julien bayou cette espèce de
mythomanie a raconté qu'il serait
premier ministre est devenu aujourd'hui
une fable grotesque un jour il est dit
que possible les derniers y croire jean
luc mélenchon près ministre jamais jean
luc mélenchon premier mito toujours plus
d'un milliard d'euros c'est ce que va
verser le géant mcdonald's au fisc
france est une première l'enseigne de
fast food a accepté de payer cet énorme
montant pour s'éviter des poursuites
pour fraude fiscale la firme américaine
a reconnu avoir transféré des fonds pays
bas et au luxembourg pour ne pas payer
l'impôt sur les sociétés en france
aujourd'hui mcdonald's a accepté cette
amende colossale s'évitant ainsi un
procès très médiatique sur ses pratiques
fiscales le groupe assure avoir retenu
la leçon et réfléchir à changer de
système ryan gosling interprétera kent
dans le film barbie les studios warner
viennent de diffuser la plastique de
l'acteur cheveux peroxydés abdos
parfaits et qu'elles sont bien nommés